it's a nerd force oh good what style
we're doing it now alright so welcome to
nerds war there's a very special nerds
war we didn't prep because I slice my
finger [ __ ]
oh um so we're doing a nerds war extreme
Adam vs. Jeff said I'm playing Adam and
I will be arguing in favor of Jeff
exactly here it goes let's do it
in this corner atom mcLaughlin you know
why Adam would win this fight
why's that because he just walk around
being labeled a solo boring burn
bouncing people off with his intense
fatness job on wookie exactly you know
you'd think that would make a difference
but before Adam could pounce and bump
you with his gut the blinding light off
of Jeff's forehead would blind Adam
hunts leaving him open for a second
attack really but you noisy but Jeff
wouldn't even see Adam coming because
Adams in disguise I don't know if you
know this Adam has a superpower but just
blends in with homeless people you just
be walking down the street Nelson yeah
that's true I've done that and they'd be
like but you think sir can have a
cigarette but you see right there as
soon as Adam jumped out and was about to
attack Jeff would interrupt him in the
middle of his thought oh that's true he
does have quite Thea and divert him into
a whole different subject about gay sex
speaking of gay sex but you've forgotten
Adams secret ability Buber gayness he
would just bend over and insert Jeff
stick right into his ass ha ha ha ha but
before he could do it Jeff would
interrupt by placing his finger inside
Adam's rectum that's true Jeff does love
to stick his finger in things it smells
like victory for Jeff and I think I
think Jeff won
no no all right we did